voilà et tu restes
dessus sur C ou sur pas B
pas
tu laisses les autres rentrer laisses
moi je lutte avec j'imagine bien avec le
vent et tout vent
derrière joli
ça tuessayes de suivre la caravane ENF
comme tu
veux au moment fa était pas droite donc
plus difficile j'aurais dû t'exprimer de
suivre la caravane mainant vous leviez
ok super
beau
[Musique]
arrière de faire un st
là je c'est bien
[Musique]
ça la sy je tiens plus va le faire
peuril tu vois ce que je veux dire je
suis désolé mais j'aurais d t'exprimer
de suivre tu vois tu aurais la fin é
bien la fin é
bienence
ou
pour maintenant c'est bien ce fait là tu
veux
recommenceron les c tout du long tu
vois
vasy pas de be sur une but làhaut ça va
pas être simple mais c'est pas
grave ça dure un petit moment le temps
de se prendre
l'AX effectivement on peut
suivre
souffle pas souffle pas on est près du
sol à gauche
put il est là le
me pas vraiment de face
désolé a beaucoup de sable souffle souff
allez à toi une phot quand il rentre sur
le blanc pas bouge pas